you know it irks me to no end when your
roommate accidentally goes into
hibernation on the couch in the den hey
you guys want to come watch football
just help me move my bear first so we
can use the couch it takes eight people
to move a bear from the couch to the
bedroom you know what they're not going
to tell you this on National Geographic
luckily I've got some tips you can use
to keep your roommate from going into
hibernation in order to keep a bear from
hibernating in your apartment you've got
to make sure it's never winter summer
24-7 360 I'll cut that off who did this
who made the drinks turn the heat up way
up here gonna get some calls from the
power company do not even swept up no
way yep sweat it actually sweat it by a
ton of ice cream the good kind make sure
that you keep the summer in the winter
theme going winter coats in the shower
there's not going to look in the shower
you've got to create the illusion that
it's actually summer it's got to be all
time Margaritaville up in here bears can
go a hundred straight days without being
disturbed I got to get a Dustbuster
bears can't read I'll tell you what
safety precautions never hurt anybody
January never happened I love
Thanksgiving but you know what there's a
lot of times for three months straight
I'll just leave it on july i missed my
dental appointment last time I wish I
was more aware of his needs because now
here I am giving up October I love
Halloween